hey everyone it's nikki bowers here i
am the social media and marketing
producer for
klas tv channel 8 and i
am here with some special guests today i
am here with
aj and joanna and they are
of j aj and joanna in the morning on
sunny 106.5 and they are here
to share some exciting news that
actually just happened on their air
so go ahead guys take it away we are
really excited about halloween and we
got dressed up
we can't let it go no but we just made a
huge announcement we feel
uh probably more than ever before las
vegas needs some holly jolly and
brightness right now so we
just flipped the button for non-stop
holiday music on sunny 1.5
so that means that every time people
turn on 106.5 sunny 106.5
they will hear holiday christmas music
right now right
yep all the way through christmas all
the way through christmas
so is this the first time that sunny
106.5 has done this
no this has been a tradition in las
vegas for a while
now sunny 106.5 has been in the las
vegas market for years
and this has been an annual tradition
that the las vegas community
really look forward to every year we
actually did a really cool contest
online recently
where we had people guess the day and
time we were gonna flip to christmas
music because
really we were getting requests like
before halloween
earlier than we have in the past but
because it's 2020
it has been a very crazy year it's been
a really interesting week
and why not get into the season a little
sooner
i i totally agree with that and actually
i was wondering
and this was actually a question for you
guys but you guys beat me already to it
um why do you think like what is it
about christmas music
that just draws people in and makes
people like what do you think it is that
makes people so happy
especially because everything we've been
going through in this crazy year
that we call 2020 people have definitely
been wanting it more i have actually
seen people who have started putting up
christmas decorations already yeah
what do you think it is about christmas
music that people just
are drawn to it i give you aj's theory
on this i feel that because for me
personally
you just go back to your childhood you
just think about these songs
when you hear the classic oldies songs
you just remember those christmases
good or bad but when you're younger and
i just really think the nostalgia of it
brings it
brings it together yeah that's what i
think too what about you joanna
i mean i'm gonna have to say aj's theory
is also joanna's theory i think it's
that nostalgic feeling
uh you can't be in a bad mood when
you're surrounded by christmas lights
and the sounds of the season it
automatically kind of takes you away
from the moment that you're in maybe
you're going through a rough time it
takes you back to a time where maybe you
really felt joy and happiness i know for
me
i always think about when my family was
together
we were opening presents i mean you just
have that warm
feeling that just makes you smile i also
want to point out that
joanna is a theory stealer
all right well you know what if we're
going to get it stealing things let's
talk about aj's jacket because he stole
that
buena's closet okay
20 20. let's talk about aj's tree
because he's copying your tree in your
shot
thank you nikki that tree went up first
yeah no it's it's it's really cool
because inside the studio here we do
decorate we go all out
there's things that you can't see that
are put in here to look like snow and
stuff to really bring it all together
because if you're gonna go big
you might as well decorate the studio
too yeah it's a fun time of year for us
to do the mornings you know when you
wake up bright and early
and you can come into a studio where
christmas lights are on
and you see snow on the ground you're
like okay i'm ready to wake up last
night i guess let's do it
so what what is your favorite kind of
christmas drink to wake up to
oh oh i would say if i had to pick a
favorite
holiday drink it would be ooh maybe like
a hot potty spiked with i don't know
gentleman jack or something yes
what about you aj i like the hard stuff
i go straight tap water
lukewarm i keep an old school that's how
i roll
[Laughter]
at the cranberry time of the year into
his water for flavor you know yeah
very good holiday fruit he likes to look
all fancy with his cranberries in his
water
yeah i i would say probably i'm a little
bit on the wilder wake up side that aj
may be in the morning
but with the cranberries i can rule out
getting any sort of christmas kidney
stones
you know what you both um said something
different i thought one of you were
gonna say like peppermint tea or
peppermint like coffee you know how
starbucks has like that peppermint latte
or something a lot of this season that's
what i thought we were gonna say
okay speaking of favorites yes i need
you guys i'm gonna put you on the spot
here
okay what is your because you're radio
djs okay so you deal with music all the
time what's your favorite
christmas song but you have to sing it
on the spot and i will say better singer
than me so aj take it away i'll sing a
little too if you want me to since i put
you on the spot i'll think one but aj
you want to sing yours first
you're gonna hate me because you put me
on the spot and i went to my backup plan
my song has no words
all right but my favorite is actually
and i just told joanna this earlier when
we were switching and she gave me an eye
roll she's like oh gosh
but i love this song it's christmas eve
sarajevo trans-siberian orchestra
and well you have the hard rock sound
you got the orchestra
sound to bring it together i actually
saw them in concert my wife
my birthday's two days after christmas
and my wife years ago took me to see
them
and it was one of the coolest concerts
i've ever seen and ever since then it's
always been like my favorite
uh song of the year no words just okay
wait can you hum me for me behind that
i need you to hum it i need you to hum
it oh it goes
dude well nutrition
and the guitar comes in he's like
[Music]
distortion the drummer's going crazy
there's a dude with big red hair he's
head banging but it's done
it's done festively i love it what about
you joanna
well listen nikki he was hiding behind
that answer because we all know
his true favorite is mariah carey is all
i want for
christmas thank you and he sings it
every morning so he's hiding behind that
answer he doesn't want to admit that
he's a huge mariah carey lover okay
and he actually sings that song in the
studio with me
and you know what he was probably afraid
to hit those notes because y'all know
mimi hit those notes and nobody can hit
it's hard he needs that water with
cranberry you know first before he can
really get those notes
even in this woman's sweater i still
can't hit those high notes he walks
around with water and cranberry and a
scarf around his neck
hitting those notes exactly that's what
really happens in the studio all right
all right wait you got a single johanna
what are you going to say what's up
oh god
[Laughter]
[Applause]
with a gentleman jack then i wouldn't
hit those notes it would have sounded a
little bit more smooth
are we gonna get in trouble because i
think there's a license on that song we
couldn't get suit sorry
we just thinking long enough mariah
carey actually when she comes to town
she told us one time that she actually
listens to sonny 106.5
because we do play a ton of mariah carey
and she knows that we play her song
over here again yes so we helped
of course fun that mariah's big giant
walk-in closets and her private islands
when we
did how is she in person you know what
she just seems like she's so
fabulous and i love it i love all of it
all the yeah
she's actually very nice i know i you
know what i get a nice vibe from her
even though she's this diva and fabulous
i definitely feel like she's a nice
person
very nice down to earth and yeah she's
got that yeah that
diva you know reputation but when i met
her and she was
she's like oh sunny with a 6.5 yeah i
love what you guys play my stuff
especially around the holidays and she
knew and
you know when she just doing her
residencies or holiday residencies here
and she would tell us that we were like
found her out in the shower hoping she
was listening
hopefully she'll hoping she would call
in
exactly we still haven't gotten that
call in done
all right did you guys want to know mine
i mean i don't have to
well that means you have to sing too
nikki
[Laughter]
i'm just trying to make y'all feel
comfortable if it's one that we know
we'll sing with you
okay mine is actually donnie hathaway's
this christmas
of course so hey hang on the mistletoe
i'm gonna get to know you better
no no no no this christmas
that's all i'm doing we weren't even
going to interrupt that because that was
beautiful
and you just totally put our renditions
together i think you just set us up you
set us up
we just turned our chairs around for you
you're going to the next round
you can definitely hear that song on
study 106.5 i love
it i mean that's literally my favorite
christmas song and then mariah's is my
second favorite
there you go there you go okay so
since we just talked about christmas
songs i have another thing that i'm
going to do and i'm going to put you
guys on the spot
we love it but this is fun okay
so i want to play a little game it's
something i created called
to sing or not to sing and the purpose
of this game is i'm gonna name off a
christmas song
and then i want you guys to say
if you are in karaoke is this something
you will sing or not sing so that's why
it's
thing or not to sing okay i love it okay
okay
and you can just say it at the same time
okay all right
white christmas not saying yeah i might
not sing that one either
too iconic don't want to butcher it
right
too iconic okay and feel free to
elaborate too just like
why okay frosty the snowman absolutely
yeah i would do that one
yeah right
everybody knows the song and yeah the
carrot while we're doing it like
really getting into the frosty vibe
absolutely and it takes you back to
childhood right
yes it does yeah i love that okay santa
baby
yes oh yeah and then i would bring my
voice up to hit that i know santa baby
he's already wearing the white fur i
mean he's already dressed for that song
perfectly i i feel a duet with that one
yes yes
okay send an email to madonna maybe
she'll hit me back yes
all i want for christmas is you yes yep
absolutely right everybody can get
behind that one i feel like it doesn't
matter
you put the pride aside everybody can
agree that's a good christmas moment
it's just fun you don't even care if
you're not hitting notes it's just funny
you know it
um let it snow let it snow let it snow
that's a thing i have a tiny tail yeah a
little age aoki
oh yeah yeah aj okay i like that
hey okay you need to brand that you need
some brand i know
yeah i just give out ideas all the time
i love that
um have yourself a merry little
christmas
i love that one that one after a few
cocktails you could really like
get into the emotion of that song so i
would bring it i'm gonna press
i'm gonna say i know sing on that one
because
if i'm gonna do the if i'm gonna go all
out for karaoke that's too slow for
for me i need something though i don't
even leave the slow stuff to joanna
everybody in the bar is crying together
all right i need a good cry
after 2020. that's the fog i was
literally about to say this is not
one i would sing because i feel like i
would cry like a baby like i would have
had a couple of cocktails yeah they're
crying so let's all need a good cry so
let's do it collectively together to a
great christmas song
this is the one where you like the this
yeah you can't
hit the notes you just pretend you're
really emotional and that's why
and then someone to go oh bless her
heart yeah i'm just really trying
[Laughter]
okay um it's the most wonderful time of
the year
yeah it's the most wonderful time
of the year right that's a good one it's
a happy holiday
it's a super happy one um i'll be home
for christmas
that's another sad one to me i would say
probably pass on that one
mm-hmm what about you i'm gonna say i'll
sing it because if she's gonna pass
this is my time to shine not sing the
slow ones
he just said he won't sing the slow one
but he's going to take it because he's
going to shine now but
there you go i love it okay um
this christmas oh you know what there's
so many good renditions to that one like
so many artists have covered that you
can really make it your own and
no one would really judge it so i would
sing it yeah
i'm gonna say no because by now i'm like
probably way too sweaty
i can't keep
[Music]
just another layer of disappointment i
promise by the way
by the way everyone it's faux fur it is
not real
yeah i mean it looks like my cat's fur
but i don't even know what this is well
no it's getting all over the studio sure
it will last all season long in the
studio
what about holly jolly christmas
oh yeah yeah get really into santa
character there i love it
yeah i love that one too well
that's all i have for you guys you guys
were so much fun and i just honestly
just think it's so cool that you guys do
this because christmas music definitely
uplifts
everyone so do you have anything else
you want to say to the audience before
we get done
well we actually have some fun surprises
planned with
eight news now this season so just stick
around we've got some big things with
you guys
all season long we're gonna have some
fun keep keep the fun
and the community spirit together here
in las vegas and
we are excited to bring you that with
non-stop holiday music
i'll echo that too because it's been
such a year i think this is going to be
a perfect year for
vegas to come together the city has been
hit so hard harder than most probably
arguably only new york really
it could be up there on that list uh and
i just feel like we're going to see the
community come together
that's why the christmas music is on
that's why we're here every morning
doing what we do
we got you back yeah so put up those
holiday lights
don't don't who cares about hoa your
neighbors what they're going to say
put them up we are ready to go and bring
that christmas spirit to las vegas
i'm wearing a women's christmas sweater
for crying out loud
you can do this vegas yes i love that
that's a great message you all
and i also just want everyone to
remember that we are vegas strong
and we are going to get through this you
know it thank you so much
no thank you happy holidays everybody
happy holidays